i'm joined by richard mcvicker now he
lost his mother father
and his sister to coven 19 in the space
of just a few weeks back in 2020 and
richard now joins us to tell us his
story richard thank you so much for
coming to talk to us
um you emailed us at sky news following
the first report of what's now called
partygate for want of a better phrase
why did you feel you wanted to email us
and tell your story
because there's obviously lots and lots
of people that have lost people but when
you hear reports on the television
of people disobeying the rules and the
regulations that we've all had to stick
to
and when we as a family went through
losing three members within three weeks
not being able to see them at all in the
hospital not being able to have a
funeral and it's just hurt and it's
still getting hurt for now when you're
still here is on the television
i've been speaking to people today who
have said that they're still coming to
terms with what happened to them during
the pandemic it's something they may
never come to terms with and the
revelations of what have been going have
been has allegedly been going on in
downing street during that time
has brought it all back
talk to me about what you were going
through at that time it started off with
one member of your family and then just
things just snowballed things just got
so much worse talk to me about what was
going on
yes it was just prior to the the
official lockdown on the 23rd of march
my father was admitted to hospital on
the saturday i spoke to my mum on the
sunday which was mother's day and she
was distraught she was tired she was
looking after me dad
and she took a turn for the worse on the
monday not knowing that covered or
anything we were just knew that there
was some kind of
virus or something going on we made the
decision not to drive over to the house
and burning on trent to visit my mum
and then on the tuesday my sister moved
in for the night to look after it and
then on the tuesday uh she was taken to
hospital my mum
and by the saturday she died
so we obviously couldn't go to see her
that week
they did manage to push the parents into
the same room so they could be together
and luckily the only remembrance we've
got at that time of them
is a picture that the nurses took of
them both lying side by side in bed
which
has absolutely destroyed my younger
sister
and the following tuesday my dad passed
away
and then a week later my elder sister
was ill
i facetimed her and she couldn't eat she
couldn't smell she couldn't taste she
got massive headaches for days on end
and
i said do you need to get to hospital
and they said no i'm following the
guidelines i'm following the guidelines
and within a week she collapsed and she
was put into a coma on a ventilator and
within five days she passed away as well
so we haven't we didn't have any time at
all at the hospital no visiting at all
richard i i really don't know what to
say in response to that it's just one of
so many stories we've been hearing here
on sky news and
when you hear people say look the prime
minister breaking the rules having a bit
of cake being with some colleagues in
the garden in the grand scheme of things
it really doesn't matter
why for you does it matter
because i and probably the rest of my
family to the left of us
are probably not grieved properly
we decided not to have any official
funerals because there was a rule of six
and there was obviously four of us
children left with our partners so that
meant eight
and we said we couldn't turn up at the
crematorium with just eight of us
standing six foot apart not being able
to hug each other and and give the send
off to our parents so we said we
wouldn't have that we decided on private
cremations for the three of them at the
later date and the first we had any
connection back with them it was about
two months later when we had the ashes
back in the in the tubes
and we had a we had a local service with
the eight of us in branston in august on
their wedding anniversary as a send-off
really and that was the first time we'd
seen each other as a family since before
they went into hospital in march
and i just feel that we haven't grieved
properly we haven't had the official
send-off and every time i see these
reports on television it just brings it
all back to think i'd have loved 10
minutes without any of them just to say
to her
and you know it doesn't matter how long
it is it just breaks my heart to see it
keep going and on and on and all these
stories coming out
richard we're looking at
a prime minister who is the rule maker
and there is a see great investigation
that has been completed we're waiting
the results of that report we're also
waiting for a criminal investigation to
to run its course and for the report to
come from that
do you need the conclusions of that
report to make your judgment on the
prime minister no no i don't i know
what's happened
whether they get the punishment they
deserve because i'm sure there's plenty
of other people but we've got our grief
we've got to live with it and you know
how long it takes us i have no idea it
could take us years to get over that
sudden death but i don't need a report
i just i'm a manager in my job
and i lead by example and i expect my
staff to do what i ask them to do and
that's the same with the leader of the
country
we all supposed to do what he asked us
to do and obviously they chose not to
richard let me just say once again thank
you so much for telling us your story as
you said you haven't griefed properly we
really appreciate you talking to us and
you've done it with such dignity and
composure i'm not sure i'm quite keeping
it together as well as you and so many
people been through so much in this
pandemic and it means so much to so many
people you talking on their behalf thank
you no problem at all thank you very
much